hello and welcome to pi data global 2021
my name is zaki i'm very happy to be
here and be your host for this session
i'd like to now welcome
richie to our session
and he is going to talk about
um
talk about products the fastest data
famed library you never heard of and
richie is the
person who coding too much he worked as
a machine learning engineer and in his
free time he liked programming and
blocking and then moved the time to
richie thank you rishi
hi welcome to my presentation
uh my name is richie jenk i've
introduced thank you um i work in a
machine learning engineer insomnia
uh xomia is a company i work for and
they sponsor
quite some time for
quite some time for me on polish
projects so i'm really grateful for them
also take a look at sumiya because we
are hiring
and
the topic of today is powers which is a
data frame library
it's an in-memory query engine and
dataframe library written from scratch
and roth
and it's got two main goal which is one
is having maximum runtime performance
and the other one is a very composable
functional api
and what this means
i will get to that later in the
presentation
so
you will have two broad topics and the
first topic is what what what is polar
in a nutshell in a high level view
and then we're going to take a look at
the polish expression language
um
and this is really the
the composite blocks of of this
composable functional api
so
um yeah the first question you could ask
is yeah white polos why are not a
daystream library
uh to the already quite saturated world
of data frame libraries
uh well the first reason is quite boring
and quite
simple
the wrist programming language did not
have a data frame library yet so it was
a cool project to get started
and
that was the first reason
i accumulated more rules or more reasons
and the second one is that moore's law
attending um that means that single
threat is code is not getting faster
anymore uh you need to rewrite your code
to
uh
to be able to benefit from hardware
trends and those hardware trends are
sorry
you may have to share a screen again
because we cannot see your screen right
now
oh
hold the car
yes
okay yes it work thank you
okay does that is my screen visible
is invisible
yes okay cool
um
yeah what it means that most large
ending means that um
the response of chip makers is
adding more codes more more course to
your cpu but
the the standard single threaded code
doesn't
benefit from this hardware trend so
numpy and phone casino threaded
in my machine i have 12 cores which
means i only
use less than 10 percent of my available
compute if i use number one
and there are also decades of database
development and then i'm talking about
logical plans very optimization
uh thinking how can we modify this this
this
this question this question we asked to
an analytical data source
in a more how can we
ask this question in a more optimal way
and in thunder onwards is executed
evenly
and that means that if you write dumb
codes you will also execute the dumb
code
and the last one is that we as a python
landscape python community we really
cover escape by r our data table is
super fast
and
yeah it was running circles around us
so
bonus is written on two foundations the
first one i already mentioned but it is
written in robs plus is programming
language that allows for memory safe
programming with
performance either
performance equal to c and c plus plus
so it doesn't give you give give away
full control but this is a concept
called the borrower checker which i
won't go into right now but if you're
interested look it up
and this
uh allows for
for safe memory safe
systems programming but it also allows
further concurrency that means that at
compile time we can be sure that
parallel pro a parallel program doesn't
have certain kind of thoughts no data
races
and the second foundation is apache aero
polos uses apache error of memory model
as corona data
and apachero is becoming the future of
big data communication
pyslar to spark uses it for security for
certification determination
and
most computers spark or no not most but
a lot of computing spark is lost in
serialization destabilization by using
aero
and standardizing the way we share
columnar data we can use a lot of a lot
less compute and
in memory we can also share data freely
so if we
agree that we both use error we can just
share pointers that means that in any
tool that also uses arrow you can just
share the data around
um
and yeah that's great
so
i will be glancing over this a bit a bit
fast but it's it's because there's a lot
to tell so always in a nutshell
comprises of
of uh more but
mostly about these things and that's one
i call them like data storage
um this means we don't have a block
manager
uh similar to fondant
this makes
performance predictable it's also very
easy to parallelize over columns
we have copy and write semantics this
means that clones are free so a whole
column is wrapped by reference counts
and if we just copy this column we just
increase the reference count
uh no no cloning of data
the proper mixing values by virtual
arrow that means that missing values are
not
not a number not a number is part of the
floating point system this means that
the schema is predictable
if we
have an integer column and we
accidentally add a missing value there
it will remain an integer it will not be
converted to a floating point column
like
uh like inpunda
um yeah it's a very sketch efficient
algorithms written from scratch with
maximum performance in mind everything
is written from scratch and rust
and it's got quality optimization and
then you can think about expression
folding predicate push down projection
push down
parallelization of physical plan these
are all
things borrowed from from data bases and
stops in detectorization um
yeah
so
one of the core things with folders are
expressions and lazy
executions um and by
changing by not choosing for eager api
but for more declarative lady api
we can
keep things um descriptive we can
describe what we want and not how we
meant it
so
uh
the
the two opposites so you have
declarative copy of procedural code
those are sort of two opposites
and in a declarative code base you would
for instance describe that you want the
cup of coffee you just say give me a cup
of coffee and how you do it it's up to
you
and in a procedural code base you could
you would not describe what you want but
how you do it so you say take five steps
then you turn around and take another
five steps to take your hand to the
coffee machine push the button put the
mark around it underneath it you get the
id you describe every step
and i think you can agree that the later
the ladder has left room for
optimization because the programmer
describes every step and i as a
as a
library designer don't
really have an idea of what you want to
do and i cannot interfere with it i need
to trust the program
well in the first one i've got an idea
what you want to do and maybe i can help
you
do this in the most optimal way
so that's sort of the
uh the goal of the progress api what you
want to achieve
so all these things i placed over um the
in the last few
slides
this led to boilers being one of the
fastest data memories out there
so here you see the results of the
aco ai database benchmark
this is a well-designed benchmark for
group by operations and
join operations on
increasing data
data set sizes
with a lot of different questions so you
cannot really optimize for a single
question because then you were there on
a lot of questions
and
yeah polaris is is fastest in every uh
in every summer in every
aggregate result every mean of all
results
um
so our data table is not making fun of
us anymore and quite landscape
so how does this compare to doneness the
because you can
typically
create for five to twenty times one-time
improvement
so
a pipeline of an hour and take five
minutes
and you typically need half of memory
requirements so pandas
needs approximately 10 times
the dataset size of this compilers needs
approximately two to four times the
dataset size of this it really depends a
bit of if you go full lazy or families
maybe
um
yeah
so
now that was sort of the
the overview that you know in the first
light view of what boilers is uh in a
nutshell now we go we come to the part
of expressions
uh and those are really the gist of the
spoilers api
um apollo's expressions you can see as
functions which take a series and output
the series
and because the input is the same as the
other two
you can compose these expressions so the
output of an expression can be the input
of an x expression
and these can be combined indefinitely
so
what you want to do with this expression
is all up to you with a as a programmer
as a user
those expressions are lazily evaluated
which means they are optimizable we can
change the order of the expression we
can see
hey you you want to do this maybe we can
replace it by this this is faster
because because of the expressiveness
and because you can combine them
indefinitely this often reduces the need
for custom python london
because the api what you can do is not
rigid
and every expression can be executed in
parallel the polaris is already super
parallel so the joints are parallel the
two by operations the aggregations are
parallel but next to that you can also
create your own parallelism by creating
expressions and
throwing them on a on polar stadium
so this may sound a bit vague but it
will become a bit more clear
so they work differently depending on
context so
an expression of context and there are
two contexts in in polars the first is
being the selection context so here we
have an example where we select
uh the common tool and then we sum this
column
and in the selection context we work in
columns this makes sense right so we
have a data frame we selected column
memory from this but we when we do a
group by operation so let's say we go by
bar
and then we
aggregate over the thumb tool we don't
want to
sum the whole problem too now we want to
strum the groups
that make sense right so
what goes into this expression is
different by context
so we first want to explore the
selection context that's the easiest to
get started
and before doing so we're going to
create a
toy dataset very simple so we import
polar spl
and we also import uh some utilities uh
call and list stands for column and
visual
people accustomed to pi spark probably
know this already and then we create the
data frame so we create a data frame
with some
fruits with some cars a lot about
strings
and we create some numerical data
and as i said we're going to first
explore the selection context
um
so context always starts from a data
frame so you start a data frame because
uh copying data in part of this
is free you just increment the reference
counter
we can create any
sub data frame from this
for free pure functions has never been
so easy
so we start the selection statement from
a data frame
and then the data flowing through the
expressions are problems in the data
frame and as i said everything is wrong
in parallel so first let's start simple
so we have data frame um and we select
column a and then we select column a
again and then we
reverse this and we add a subject so we
add suffix to the name
and this column you see here is actually
synthetic sugar for
for this
so if we run this you see we select
column a
and second we select column a but we
reverse the order
so
yeah
you can also do
select more columns
in a single expression so the
expressions are expanded so we can say
okay polaroid of all
with this we select all columns
and then we again can select all and
then do the dot reverse dot suffix
and under the root all these expressions
are evaluated in their own software soft
expressions
so you for every column this
pl that all those reverse gets expanded
to column a that refers to suffix to
column b dots and suffix
you get the id
and as you can see we created a new data
frame
with first
the normal columns of the data frame and
next the reverse columns of the data
frames
next to just simple selections we can
also do aggregations in the selection
context so we can select our columns and
then compute the sum of this
and next we select our columns and
compute the min of these
and if we run this we get a very wide
data frame with
uh the results
and
people familiar with not described
you can sort of think of this as a
describing standards because it's super
customizable
how what kind of description you want
um
but also you can also combine
expressions that produce a full column
for instance here we
select column a and then we compute the
rank of a
and if we only run this we
create a full column
right
but if we run
this one we create a
a single value because this is negative
but you can combine them anything in a
single expression
uh so if you produce a single value that
will will just be broadcasted over the
size of the data frame
um
so
yeah so you can combine aggregations and
normal projections
um
this sort of wraps up the selecting uh
stuff there are more stars of the
selection you can also select very
effects you can also select everything
and then exclude things you don't want
selected so you go sort of the other way
around i know what i don't want
i can also select the details and if
you've got more ideas for selections
please make an issue and we'll add that
as well
um now we're going to talk a bit about
filtering
so first we're going to start really
simple
a filter is uh
again
um
yeah very simple we just say test
friendly filter and then we add pedicure
so we say
um we want to filter
where the common foods equals banana so
the value of common fruits equals banana
and as you can see here we
stop data frame where
all the food values are banana so this
is quite simple
um
as i said point of expressions are
lazily evaluated so you can
create functions where you create these
expressions because i'll assign them to
variables and use them later because we
resign
assign a variable equal to nana but it
doesn't do anything yet
we can also
filter
not on the data frame but on the
expression level so here we select on
fruits and then we filter equal banana
and then we count and count the number
of values
[Applause]
that's equal to banana and as we see
that's similar to the height of the data
frame we created here
um
and here we
from the values
so
we can
so so filtering can be done on two
places you can do it on a whole data
frame level or you can do it in the
expressions itself
and
we can
just sort this slide sort of shows all
the things you can do in a single
selected
so you can select just normally select
columns you can do aggregations here we
compute the mean
you can do the filters and then some
later
[Music]
and you can also do normal arithmetic so
you can
use polar expressions just in arithmetic
you can you can square them you can
compute the mean you can divide them
um they also support mu by u function
you can use a numpy dot exponential for
instance on an expression so this would
also work
if i imported nobody i don't think i
have
but yeah you get id so this would also
work
so
um
yeah these all these things you can
throw on a select statement this will
all be ran in parallel
and it's super easy to create a parallel
pipeline like this
um
this is another example here
so the previous expressions were all on
a single expression value
but you also often want to combine
columns from different values so so if a
predicate is true i want to take the
value of column a and otherwise i take
the value of column b for instance
or here we have an example in part so we
create upon the date frame we assigned
code new
uh we assigned it to equal to b and then
went fruits not equals banana then we
assigned the w to minus one so we
modified the date frame in place
and in polars we just say they
add a colon
and then we use a when then otherwise
expression
so the wind takes predator when common
fruit equals banana then we take column
b and otherwise
we fill in the value minus 1. and this
is quite similar to a python if-else
expression but then it works on
powerless columns
and you can even keep combining those
predicates so you can say when then when
then when that otherwise and this would
be similar to
uh
like how using python if at least at
least
at least
or maybe in the new
python version we have a match i think
that should be on this
um
yeah and here we have another example i
will clone with this song
this shows a bit how you
uh
can write a pure
polar pipeline combined with sequential
and parallel code because not everything
can be done in parallel some columns are
dependent from other columns
so first start with with python with
pandas components you often see these
almost data frameable dot python pipe
and as you can imagine those are
sequential by nature so everything is
sequential by nature and it's all on a
female thread
and what you also often see in the valve
is that
people want to write your functions
because you don't want the original data
frame to be modified so
often something starts with the df.clone
which means that our data needs to be
copied and upon us this is not a cheap
copy this is an expensive coffee so it
doubles your data
and it takes a lot of computing
in polaroids we
we don't even need a data frame we can
just
return an expression that takes columns
if we know the schema
and aud so this is a sequential function
those two are run in parallel
and then we have to select and those are
also run in parallel so you can combine
sequential and parallel code
now we go to a different
context this is a group by some text and
the data flowing through the expressions
in the group by context are not columns
but those are the groups in the google
operation
and those can have two values so let's
let's uh explore them
so we start very simple so we have the
data frame we go by default
and then we take the aggregations of the
column cards
and if we don't aggregate it we just get
a list we get a list of the cars so here
you see the group banana and the tesla
cars beetle audi beetle and group apple
as the car's beetle people
but again here we can start
making more complex expressions so we
can add a filter
so here we filter all the cars that
equal beta pedal and then we count
uh the number of beetles for instance
so now we know per group how many
beetles we have
as you can see complex aggregations are
very customizable and very
very easy to compose to change
okay um
yeah and we can keep continuing
in front of us i believe we have some
sort of flexibility with the
shift and some but if you want to
combine
things um so you want to do a shift and
an enrolling window then
i don't know how you can can do this
thing in parliament in polish you can
just
keep adding an expression
uh most of the time so there are a lot
of expressions and
they're taking that if they can uh
take in a group or they produce a value
they produce another group
so when we take column a we reverse them
and then we compute the rolling mean
so that that's this problem
and then second one we do the same but
then we compute the sum
and as you can see it's correct so the
sum of nine and no nine the sum of four
and one is five
now we're going to get get to
sort of
window functions and window functions
are sort of expressions with superpowers
so window functions are aggregations in
the selection context so not in group by
context
which means we can
go by over different
groups
in a single
flex statement so we can group by over
bar because a group over two and we can
group over n and we can do this all in
parallel all in a single selected
so the syntax for this is is borrowed
from
postgres and also the name so you take a
column two
then you do some aggregation expression
and then you say over the groups and
then the groups themselves
so that's that's how the window function
is defined
and
again you can keep combining expressions
so
in this middle part you can combine
multiple
multiple composites of expressions
so
so let's take a look so we select
we sort by fruits and then we select
cars a let's start simple
so here we have the data we select
and then we
take
and we compute the list of the groups
fruit
and if we do that so we have to group
fruits apple for instance
and
the values in the group apple are three
and four and this is also what we get
back three and four
and the values in group banana
are one two and five and this is also
what we get better
okay we take some questions from the
audience okay um someone asking is there
a possibility to work with geo data
in geo panda
um
not geo fungus no
no okay
okay what features are printed next
database style in this
prediction
they're not product
and others desired
can you type now
um i see some questions the daytime
sport is good
there are days and date times um
time zones are coming up
um but there are days day times and
times so so that's in there um
a lot of slides so okay
let me wrap it up so the window
functions are
super powerful they can combine
different aggregations they can also do
the pandas transform people's familiar
with it
so
that's sort of the top there are a lot
more things there's cool lazy executions
with
with query optimizations it's feature
complete that's got joys as of joins
time series handling
and the rules
it it's also working as a possible
back-end for more
tools so now i'm ready for the question
okay
okay
one more question is is porter api
exactly the same as pandas is there any
change needed
if code is similar to pandas is it
changing yeah it's the the api is
different from comments
so um
yeah there is change needed it will uh
and if you there is some union with
pandas api but if you if you write
boilers like your extenders you will
have quite a slow folder
so they join and they go by so far but
yeah optimal polaris is functional
progress
i think i'm going to read some questions
so i i i see a question compiler
compound to small binary that'd be epic
uh it's already
quite it's 10mb the binary it's similar
to
uh the panda size without anything the
only requirement still is numpy
which we might get out so implies a and
b
so maybe we will
go to a polar only binary
um do you have oh this is the question
piracy thanks infestation do you have
examples of what an equivalent of upon
the supply lander would look like in
parliament
an example you showed that the python
method was
translated
how did we compare for io iowan power is
a lot faster than paul does it has one
of the fastest cc courses
um it's got a super fast property parser
and an apply would look like this
so you can select a colony
column
apply
and there you have a lambda
so
this will run
so now we don't don't do anything which
islam but this this takes part
a polar series um
how i apply the group sorry
um
yeah
so this applies every group
so you can do
eight times two so here it's column a
um and we
we cannot produce the same name so we
call this a new
voila so here we take and apply which
got flow code but this is not needed of
course
right okay next question thank you she
our time is over
could you please move the discussion to
the snack or get a ton
and thank you richie to talk and for
being part of the party global 2021 and
thank you so much